[MUSIC PLAYING]
REAZUL AHSAN: I am
Dr. Reazul Ahsan,
a visiting scholar of MIT UTM
Malaysian sustainable city
program.
I am presenting two stories
of development induced
displacement in Malaysia.
One follows up with communities
affected by a hydroelectric dam
in East Malaysia.
The other addresses an ongoing
housing development project
on the southern tip
of peninsula Malaysia.
Malaysia is one of the world's
fastest developing nations.
Under its own militia program,
the government [INAUDIBLE]
be a developed country by 2025.
Accordingly, federal
and state governments
are intensively investing in
infrastructure development,
especially in housing, energy,
and manufacturing sectors.
However, many national
infrastructure development
programs fail to
consider indigenous
poor and marginalized
communities, who
have very limited voice in
planning these mega projects.
From 1980 to 1990,
almost 10 million people
were displaced in South Asia
due to development projects,
like hydroelectric dams.
The process known as
development induced displacement
remains a global challenge
for socially sustainable
development planning.
Sarawak, one of two
Malaysian estates
on the island of Borneo,
is a real example
of development
induced displacement
due to hydroelectric dams.
Sarawak is home to
2.37 million people,
and its 27 indigenous
ethnic communities
speak 45 different languages.
In Malaya, these indigenous
groups are known as Orang Asli.
Beginning IN the year 1994,
the Sarawak's government
initiated the second largest
hydroelectric dam in Asia.
In the name of region
wide economic development,
the dam inundated
1,700 hectares of land
in the interior zone
of Bakun, and displaced
more than 10,000 Orang Asli
from their home and their land.
To learn more about those
displaced communities,
I journeyed to Bakun.
These displaced
indigenous communities
have been relocated
next to the Bintulu City
on land allocated by the
government, which is now
known as Village [INAUDIBLE]
Before the resettlement,
indigenous communities
harvested their everyday needs
from river and forest in Bakun.
But this new location
is far from their source
of livelihood.
Every week many
displaced villagers
make a long journey
to Bakun to fish
and get their food
from the forest.
Their government appointed
village leader, Mr. [INAUDIBLE]
said, that it was a
completely new life for them
after displacement.
To him, the new home was a
jungle far away from the river
essential to their livelihood.
SPEAKER: It's very
totally new to our people.
It's totally new.
Because they are used
to the way of life.
They're used to the
way of-- how they
do living in the old place.
So when we moved
to this new place,
so can see that all the
area here is jungle.
REAZUL AHSAN: As a
part of the relocation,
they also claimed compensation
from the government.
SPEAKER: There is Bakun
Development Committee, BDC.
So we have a thick book that
we pass to the government
so that they can study about
our land, how much do they
compensate for
land, and how much
do they compensate for
the garden, rubber, paper,
and so on.
And what about our house?
And how are you going
to compensate the house?
REAZUL AHSAN: However,
the compensation
wasn't enough to start fresh
in their resettlement location.
SPEAKER: It's [INAUDIBLE]
for this, because they
are using the government rate.
REAZUL AHSAN: I helped
team group discussions
with men and women in
the indigenous community
to understand the
challenges they
faced since their relocation.
[INAUDIBLE] interviews
say the greatest challenge
at the relocation site
was, insufficient access
to land to sustain them.
At least one member
of every family
travels back to the dam areas
for the daily intake needs,
two hours there from
the new location.
This travel is costly, and also
raises their daily living cost.
To compensate, some have
started living semi-permanently
in the dam area, collecting
food under compromised living
condition, while their families
remain in the new settlement
areas.
[INAUDIBLE] is one of
the indigenous people who
moved to the dam area to
minimize her family's living
costs, and harvest the
food from the rivers.
SPEAKER: Half an hour
from here to their house.
REAZUL AHSAN: Back in
the settlement area,
some elders feel
isolated and have
no bond with the community
since becoming displaced.
[INAUDIBLE] Is one of them.
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
REAZUL AHSAN: After being
displaced for 16 years,
the villagers now settle
into normal daily routines,
but they're still struggling to
subsist only on the new lands,
and improve condition
for the next generations.
On the southernmost tip
of peninsula Malaysia,
and ongoing story of
development induced displacement
is unfolding.
Iskander Malaysia, it is an
old development authority
in the state of Johor, is aiming
to house three million people
by 2025.
One of the region's
largest new housing
projects Country
Garden in Danga Bay
is being built in a variety
of [INAUDIBLE] coastal areas
between two rivers.
Within an aim to accommodate
about 9000 new residents,
Country Garden is
an eviction threat
for the indigenous people
living in Danga Bay area
for hundreds of years.
The project pushed them to
the edge of the developing
boundary, and left no
other options for them
but to displace.
Mr. [INAUDIBLE], director
of Iskander Malaysia,
knows about the indigenous
history of Danga Bay.
SPEAKER: [INAUDIBLE] is also
where we have the fisherman
relation and we have the
indigenous group, which call
[INAUDIBLE].
The British used
call them sea gypsy.
REAZUL AHSAN: In the
questions of land right,
[INAUDIBLE] says.
SPEAKER: It's not enough to
get [INAUDIBLE] So whether they
like it or not, it's
just a matter of time.
This will have to relocated
to [INAUDIBLE] the area.
REAZUL AHSAN: I asked him what
alternatives are available.
SPEAKER: The land there itself,
is belong to third parties.
So we only got two choice,
is that [INAUDIBLE] the area,
or we have to relocate
them to other area.
Is not that easy for us to
[INAUDIBLE] It's a growing
community, and maybe
for start, 100 ,
150 families is sufficient
for to say there.
But not as the community
grow double or triple,
we still have the [INAUDIBLE].
We also need to be realistic.
We're not talking about
50 years ago, [INAUDIBLE]
ago, where we have abundant
of land on seafront.
REAZUL AHSAN: Indigenous
community leader [INAUDIBLE]
also says land right
and displacement
are longstanding issues.
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
REAZUL AHSAN: To his community,
the Country Garden project
was unexpected.
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLSIH]
REAZUL AHSAN: They protested,
and reported the land
occupation to the police.
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
REAZUL AHSAN: Mr.
[INAUDIBLE] a leader
among local fishermen,
also suffered
due to the reclamation process.
SPEAKER: [NON-ENGLISH SPEECH]
REAZUL AHSAN: According to Dr.
Colin G. Nicholas, director
of Center for Orang Asli
Concern, in Malaysia,
resettlement or
relocation can never
be a solution for displaced
indigenous communities.
COLIN NICHOLAS: This
first thing that
happens in the resettlement
scheme is you break down
the social structure.
Indigenous peoples are
not interested in land,
they are interested in
their traditional land
and their culture.
REAZUL AHSAN: Across the
river from Danga Bay,
Iskander Development Authority
has produced an ecotourism
development plan for
Kompang [? Sona ?]
Melayu, a village for
traditional Malay people,
known as Bumiputras.
However, the authority has no
corresponding development plan
for the indigenous
village in Danga Bay.
Incorporating this community
into Kompang [? Sona ?] Melayu
plan, could prevent
its displacement,
and protect its indigenous
culture and tradition.
The village currently operates
a Cultural Heritage Center,
which villagers believe could
be a launchpad for a similarly
ecotourism development strategy.
Recognizing the inevitability
of development and displacement,
communities often
have generated ideas
about how to mitigate
the social impacts.
Engaging in
participatory planning
with the indigenous
community could
sustain the land,
livelihood, and culture
for them, and for the
following generations.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]